ANDREW SULLIVAN: My
name is Andrew Sullivan.
I am a product manager here in
the Bay Area out of Sunnyvale
for G Suite Security.
And I'm joined by
Pascal, Ryan, and Red.
Pascal?
PASCAL DALLA TORRE:
Hello, everybody.
My name is Pascal Dalla Torre,
and I've been working at Veolia
for two years and a half.
My role is head of
technology office.
The team basically deals with
cybersecurity, software asset
management, enterprise
architecture,
and design authority.
Veolia, just few words about
it, it's a large group company.
160,000 people
are working there.
And we are focusing basically
on three major businesses--
water distribution, waste
recycling, and energy.
RYAN SEIT: Hey, guys.
I'm Ryan from Casper.
The director of IT.
We oversee all corporate
IT, retail IT as well.
A little bit about Casper--
we are a disruptor in
the mattress industry,
direct to consumer
through e-commerce
and recently brick-and-mortar.
And usually, Casper
at least, what
we do is when we introduce a
new person, we do a fun fact.
So I'm just going
to do a fun fact.
I'm originally from
Brooklyn, and I
play drums in a hardcore band.
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
Hi, everyone.
Hello.
Good afternoon.
My name is Red.
I am from Globe Telecom.
I'm actually from
the Philippines.
Globe Telecom, right now, is
the leading telecommunications
in the Philippines,
from wireless, to wired,
to all types of
telecommunication services.
We're also venturing in
entertainment system solutions
right now, including e-sports
and YouTube and everything
else.
I've worked as a digital
workplace manager in Globe
for about six years
now, almost six years.
And we've been a G Suite
customer for that long period
of time as well.
We're trying to explore GCP.
Yeah, I'd love to share more
details to you guys later.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Great,
thanks very much, Red.
Can we advance the slide please?
Thank you.
So a quick reminder,
you've probably
seen this in previous sessions.
We are using Dory today.
So if you have a
question, please
feel free to add it
to the Dory as we
go throughout the
conversation, and we'll
bring up some of
the top questions
at the end of the session today.
Sam, my esteemed colleague
here, is actually
leading that effort, and
you'll hear from him.
Or save your
questions for the end,
and we'll bring them
back on the mics.
So question for y'all, how
many of you are G Suite admins
today?
OK.
Right.
Yes.
My test to count,
at the very least.
Great.
So I expect you'll have some
good questions for this panel.
I would love to start
this conversation
by learning a little bit more
about our worldwide panel's
environment.
So starting with
you, Pascal, can you
tell us about your
environment and how
you're using G Suite today?
How many users you support?
What is a day in the
life look like for you
as an administrator?
And thinking about that,
what's the biggest or most
unique security
problem that you face?
PASCAL DALLA TORRE: So
basically, at Veolia,
the G Suite story
started in 2012.
Basically, we did this
study at that time
because we wanted to
challenge the solution we had,
which was Microsoft Office.
So we did that study.
It didn't take so much
time to realize that we
have to move to G Suite.
So it started in 2013, with
whole core services, basically.
So we did a massive rollout
in all our business units.
Just for information, we
have like 60 business units
all over the world.
So as I said before,
it's 160,000 people.
So all are concerned
about that, even
though we don't have so many
user accounts, around 100,000.
So we had three major
concerns at that time,
which were 2-step verification.
We wanted to roll out accounts
with a 2-step verification
because we are massively
using single sign-in,
and all our solutions
basically rely on the strength
of Google identity.
So it's mandatory for us to
have a single sign-in in place
and 2-step verification.
And the third point is also a
tool that we have developed,
which is called a DIMA, for
Digital Identity Management.
It's basically related
to all our accounts
and the lifecycle
of our employees.
When they get into the
company, when they move.
So it's the whole challenge that
we have to face at that time.
And as for the
administration, we
are currently doing something
we call our technical debt.
But we will talk about that
maybe a little bit later.
And the idea behind it is that
since we massively rolled out
all those services, we didn't
pay so much attention just
with security at the beginning.
So now we have to get rid
of these technical depth,
and we can detail
this in a few minutes.
RYAN SEIT: So at
Casper, we've got
approximately 600 to
700 people, far less
than both Red and Pascal here.
But that said, they're
dispersed throughout the world.
We have offices in
Berlin, Toronto, New York,
and San Francisco,
as well as stores all
throughout domestic US,
some in Canada as well.
So supporting all those users
gets a little difficult.
I would say the biggest thing
or the difficulty that we've
run into is, as a retail
company, with holidays,
you have to hire.
And then there's a lot
of attrition in retail,
so a lot of user
accounts get provisioned
and then quickly deprovisioned.
And so being able to turn
those accounts over quickly
is very critical
for us, which we've
been able to use G Suite for.
Aside from that, we use all
the core G Suite functionality,
such as drive, docs,
things like that,
to collaborate with all
of our users in real time.
Previous to that, we were
using Office 365, which is OK.
But when you're trying to
collaborate on a last minute
presentation for
a board meeting,
it gets very difficult
in PowerPoint.
So Slides makes
that a bit easier.
Past that, a day in
the life of myself--
I think we're covering
that at this point--
a day in the life
for us is we have
IT stand up in the morning,
starting with meditation.
It's five minutes.
The team looked at me like
I was crazy when we started,
but honestly, it's
super helpful just
to get in a good mindset for
the madness that will ensue
throughout the rest of the day.
So we start off with our SLAs.
We go through our roadmap for
the quarter, for the year,
to make sure we're all
adhering to the due dates
that we've agreed to.
Meetings galore, as
I'm sure everybody
can attest to with all the
different cross-functional
partners that we have
to ensure that we're all
aligned on the rapidly moving
targets of the business.
And let's see.
Unique security, I think
I already mentioned that
with the attrition in retail.
So that's about it.
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
So with Globe,
we're actually about
almost 18,000 employees.
We're scattered across
the Philippine islands.
That's about 7,107, depending
on the tide, whether it's
rising or low tide.
But we've been a
G Suite customer
for about six years now.
And as I mentioned
earlier, we're
using quite heavily on G Suite,
specifically on productivity,
Drive.
We're subscribed to
unlimited storage and all.
Within those 17,000
workforce, majority of them--
it's probably around
9,000 regular employees.
The other are
temporary employees.
So with that in mind, that would
be our security concerns as
well because we have an
unlimited storage of data,
and at the same time,
we're scattered everywhere.
Since we're scattered,
a lot of our concerns
mostly in our devices and
our identity and making sure
it's self-service in
terms of troubleshooting
all of these things.
And we're able to fix that
through MDM, G Suite MDM.
And it's quite
weird because those
that are not within
our head office
are actually the most to
adapt quickly, rather than
the ones in the head office.
Probably because they have
become self-reliant and making
sure that they're
following instructions
and all of these things.
Day in the life--
I've been working for
Globe for six years,
and I'm handling
apps and devices.
So every employee apps
and employee devices
goes through me in
terms of approval,
in terms of the roadmaps and
all of those requirements.
So we've been trying to
move everything to the cloud
and also to mobile-first.
So that's what I do every
day-- and also coordinate
with our security team.
We have our command center,
which basically monitors
all of our network traffic,
specifically handing
one of the largest
network infrastructure
in the Philippines.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Great.
So thinking about
this environment based
on your own experience, there's
a few things I'll follow up on.
But I'll ask the
big question first,
which is, if you're
a G Suite admin,
what is one thing
you should do right
now to improve your security?
And we'll start
with you, Pascal.
PASCAL DALLA TORRE: Well,
as a cyber security officer,
I would say when you
roll out Google service,
whatever G Suite
service, you have
to think about the best
compromise between the best
experience, user experience,
and security risks.
So what does it mean?
If you don't do that,
what is going to happen
is you will generate what we
call a big technical debt.
I'll give you some figures,
because as I mentioned
before, when we started
to roll out, massively,
our G Suite services, we
pay attention to user-first.
And we said, OK, we want the
better experience for them
because we were also
convinced that it was the best
choice that we did.
But we didn't take care so much
about security at that time.
OK, so now what we
realized is that, I'll
give you some figures.
We have, for instance,
1,400 Google Groups
without any manager or owners.
So it means we have no
idea about the spams
for those groups, for instance.
We have over 100 internal
domains which are not compliant
related to antispoofing.
So we have to work about that.
We have also some figures
really tied to [INAUDIBLE]..
We have 1,000 users who still
benefit from this service.
So the idea behind it, if you
give you those figures, that
this huge technical debt,
we have to solve that.
So the best way to do it is,
of course, when you start,
is to put in place some
KPIs, automatic ones.
Because then you put
a process and you're
able to trust what's
going to happen
and the evolution
about those services.
Again, with a company like
ours, large-scale company,
you've got to do that.
Otherwise everything is
going to be out of control.
And one other point is also
to take the do good measure
to put the risk under control.
And this is what
we've been doing now
for quite some months.
And it's hard and very
painful to go to business unit
and to say, could you please
justify why you're still
using this [INAUDIBLE]?
Which, if you don't have
any business reasons,
you're not supposed to use that
anymore, at least from a user
perspective.
So it's a long, long journey.
But one also point
I wouldn't mention
here, which is quite essential,
is to do it little by little.
I know it takes quite a while.
But if you think
that you are going
to solve everything at once,
it is not going to work.
So think about this.
The best compromise between user
experience and security risk.
Put KPIs, automatic ones,
and take action measure,
and put this process in place
to have another view about that.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Pascal,
I'd like to follow up
on that a little bit.
You talked about using
KPIs to measure progress.
Can you talk a little about how
you use our tools, or perhaps
home-built tools, to
monitor those KPIs
and keep an eye on risk?
PASCAL DALLA TORRE:
Yes, it's true
that we've been using
also Security Center,
like built-in
dashboards-- quite useful.
Of course, we have developed
also some productivity tools
in order to check a few
things that we didn't
have natively with Google.
We are also using
investigation tool,
which is a quite powerful
tool where we could just
do some requests in order
to have some figures,
as I mentioned before.
We've also been using
tools like Email Log Search
to confirm that there's some
traffic going in some SMTP
relays, for instance.
All those kinds of things.
So it's both a compromise
between the native tools
that Google could provide
and also the tools
that we have developed.
ANDREW SULLIVAN:
Great, thank you.
Ryan.
RYAN SEIT: Sure.
So I would say
two-step verification,
two-factor authentication,
day one, turn it on.
Super important,
especially if you're
a larger company, or a company
of interest, or a disruptor.
Casper becomes a target for
many of our competition.
So we want to make
sure that we are
taking the steps to mitigate
as many malicious attacks as
possible.
Two-step verification is a
great way to start doing that.
Past that, incident management
protocols are super important.
You don't really think
of a plan of action
when something goes wrong
until something goes wrong.
And by then, it's too
late, and you're just
operating on adrenaline, and
it just turns into a big mess.
Speaking from experience,
I've done that before
and learned a lot.
Being able to figure out
the course of action,
the parties that
need to be notified,
the notification schedule, and
having templates of information
that you're sending out to
the team with some variables
that you're changing, obviously,
so you're not reinventing
the wheel or writing an
entirely new email every time
you deal with a security issue.
I find that's super important.
In addition to that, a
change advisory board
is super helpful.
When you're looking
to implement changes,
having an established change
advisory board with influencers
in the company,
senior leadership,
you want those people involved.
So when you do
recommend changes,
they are vetted properly.
And then they
become, essentially,
the people who are championing
the change for you.
So when it comes
from the top down,
it's adopted much, much
quicker by the end user.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Follow
up question for you, Ryan.
We talk a lot about
security keys.
We're very proud of the
fact that security keys
can help you reduce
the risk of phishing,
reduce the risk of
account hijacking.
Sometimes, security
keys have a perception
of being difficult to use.
How did you overcome
that perception
among your user community?
RYAN SEIT: That's a tough one.
So we're still rolling out
security keys to our fleet,
but we do have a group of
outsourced contractors,
as well as our retail
teams, that are using
security keys on a daily basis.
Now, for new users who aren't
familiar with the protocols
of the company, super easy.
Just give them the
security key and tell them,
this is what you do.
But when it's a user who's
used to how it was before,
it gets a little
bit more difficult
explaining to them the benefits
of utilizing security keys
for two-step authentication.
There are other methods of
the two-step authentication
as well.
Obviously, through your
phone, Google Authenticator.
There are third
parties that do it too.
But security keys I find
is a great first step
of that two-factor
authentication.
Not everybody is going to be
keen on carrying something
around with them all the time.
So having the backup of a phone
for that verification process
is helpful.
But we are working on it on
the corporate side, for sure.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Great.
Thank you.
Red, what's the one thing
every G Suite admin should
do to improve their security?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ: Oh,
look at it end-to-end.
I guess it's more of a--
because my role actually looks
at devices and application--
so it's more of I can have an
end-to-end visibility with how
the user experience is.
I guess it's really
more of that.
So create a roadmap.
Have the specific solution
each of the points
that you have to consider,
from the log-in experience
to multi-factor authentication,
to MDM, up until the SSO
that you've implemented
in your application.
So it's something that
we've been working on
over the last four years,
and we're trying to make sure
that we have that in place.
Also, I like what
you said earlier.
I think that's true.
I'm going to add to something
what Ryan said earlier.
Having a change
management board.
And at the same time, something
to do with our security
posture right now.
Since we're a teleco, we have
to comply with our version
of GDPR, which is DPA.
We utilize the DPA
to make sure that we
have funding if we need to put
more security layers on top
of what we have right now.
So use what you
have, and also make
sure you have that
roadmap in place.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: What's the
name of the regulation again?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
DPA, so Data Privacy App.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Can
you comment a little bit
about how you do
your audits for DPA
and how you use tools from
us as well as your own
build tools for that?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ: So
we have plenty of tools
that we're using, from
third-party solutions
to native Google solutions,
such as Security Center,
from both GCP and
also with G Suite.
But more so we also
have our internal team
which is building not really
sophisticated but more
of automating that
flow, from using Splunk
to different
third-party solutions.
Yeah, we usually have
security incidents
that we can actually use
Security Center to make
sure we check all the
steps and also they
track the user's
usage, in a sense.
And that's how we utilize G
Suite Security Center, more
of the alerts as well.
Actually, earlier today,
I received an alert
from Security Center stating
that this specific account has
been probably been
a phishing account.
But apparently part of our
Security Command Center team
was actually testing
that functionality
that's abuse@globe.com.ph,
so basically it
sends an alert to everyone if
we notice some sort of abuse
for SMTP or Relay or
for any other activity.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Got it.
Great.
Thank you.
So thinking about
best practices,
I'm going to ask a
few additional best
practice questions.
But what are some of the
pitfalls, or blind spots,
or trouble spots
that you've run into?
And how are you able to overcome
them in the last few years?
PASCAL DALLA TORRE:
Well, I'll start.
I keep on to respect the order.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: We don't
have to go in order.
We can go in a different
order, by the way.
Ryan, why don't you start.
We want to change it.
It's a little too orderly.
RYAN SEIT: Well,
my initial answer
was we haven't really
run into too many issues.
Fingers crossed, all
those things crossed.
I'm sure as soon as I said
that the place is on fire back
in New York.
But one thing that we've run
into is user authentication.
Not two-factor,
nothing like that.
But third-party services.
So a lot of people still
use usernames and passwords
for a service that is not
directly related to G Suite.
The great thing about this,
and maybe I'm getting ahead
of myself a little bit-- this
is what happens when you put me
on the spot--
using the native SSO
services from G Suite
to link that application
or service into G Suite
so it authenticates
through that,
mitigating the need for
a username, password.
Sometimes provisioning
a user automatically
and deprovisioning
them automatically,
that has alleviated a lot of
headache across the company
where people were either
forgetting their usernames
or passwords, or just signing up
for services they shouldn't be
and gaining access to services
that they shouldn't be.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Pascal?
PASCAL DALLA TORRE: OK,
so at Veolia, we faced,
nearly two years ago--
I think it was in May 2017--
a large-scale phishing attack
directed at, basically, Google
customers.
So as a classical
phishing attack,
the users received an email
from an attacker who pretended
to be a contact of one of them.
And it was basically a link to
an application which falsely
claimed to be a Google Doc.
And by this phishing
link, it was
supposed to access
to user accounts
in order to basically steal
all contact information.
And then the idea behind it
was to send again this message
to other contacts and so on.
So Google did its job disabling
all the links, removing
the log-in page and so on.
So what we have
learned from that,
basically, is that first of
all, we can use the customized
settings from Google.
We have some that we have
applied at the domain level,
like identifying links behind
shortened URLs, for instance.
It's a bit technical, but it's
one feature you could put.
Also related to scan linked
images, things like that.
And also some
warning prompt when
you click on a link that
goes to an untrusted domain,
then all of a sudden
pops up a warning, which
is quite efficient as well.
So those are basically the
tools that Google can provide
and you can put in place.
The second part I
would mention is--
I come back to a point
that Ryan already
talked about-- is
related to security keys.
So security keys,
it's probably today
the best second-step
verification method
that we have against phishing.
Better than Prompt
Authenticator and so on.
So I mentioned before that
it was one of the key points
for Veolia that time in 2013.
Even though we have
evolved and the users we
recommend that
they use prompt, we
have a very
sensitive population,
which are super admin accounts.
So we have the G Suite
super admin accounts.
We have the GCP
We have all the Cloud
platform super admin accounts.
And the third population
is also all super admins
related to SES
solution that we have
integrated in our environment.
I mentioned like for CRM,
HR, payroll, and so on.
And we have very
sensitive information.
So what we've done so
far, we have identified
those populations, and we
started to actually create
a dedicated G Suite account.
Needless to mention
that some of them
were using their regular
accounts in order
to do some sensitive action.
But I'm sure Veolia is not
the only company, between us.
So we started to roll
out security keys.
So pay attention to one point.
And maybe we can talk
about that again later.
The security now that has
been provided by Google,
the Titan key with
the Bluetooth mode
is very good as user experience.
And nobody can claim
that they have an issue
because the security cannot be
introduced in their Chromebooks
or other devices.
And so it does not work anymore
since it works contactless,
which is very good.
And the last point is--
don't give in to people who come
to you and say, [INAUDIBLE],,
but today I have
forgotten my security key.
It was much easier
with Prompt or SMS.
You know, I always have
my telephone with me.
And I tell them that
when you go shopping,
you take your credit
card, don't you?
And if you just forget
once your credit
card, the second time, sure.
You won't forget it.
And it's the same
with a security key.
And this is what
we have been doing.
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
On our end--
I have two things, actually.
One is MDM and the
other one was SSO.
So about probably
three years ago,
so we've started the venture
of trying to introduce MDM
to our employees.
The thing is, we were kind of
having hesitation from them.
Specifically because it's
going to be on their device.
First question
was, are you going
to check my personal files?
Or all of these things that
they're more conscious of,
and that's good.
They're more conscious of what
happens to their accounts.
But it took them
a while to realize
that it's better to have the
MDM in place rather than not.
So there was an event
three years ago.
One of top guys in
Globe lost their phone
while they were in Barcelona.
So they're doing the MWC event.
So they were there, and the
first thing that they did
is actually they contacted me.
And it was nighttime
in Manila at the time.
And I had to do something.
And I told them, did you
enable MDM on your end?
Or they were able to set it up?
And they said, yes.
And I said yeah, good thing.
Because we're able
to lock the phone.
And actually he was the one
who championed MDM across Globe
because of that experience.
And we kind of made
sure that everyone
knew about what happened.
And in the leader circle,
they were very well aware
of what's going to
happen if they don't turn
on their MDM on their phones.
The second one was the SSO.
So right now,
because of the road
map that we have
for the experience,
people are now focusing
on all their applications.
They want to have the SSO
experience across all.
And they want
Google login there.
Because before Google login, we
have our own internal solution
that was supposed to be
doing that functionality.
But because of
albeit an old one,
and it's not something that
was able to accommodate
all the functionality
that we requested,
they were having a hard
time logging in, or rather
integrating their
application to that solution.
So it was something that
we wanted to push for it.
So right now, all of our
software SSO service solutions,
they're all using Google login.
And since then, we haven't
experienced any account
compromise whatsoever.
We just made sure that everyone
gets two FA at the onset,
and we disable those things
that should be disabled.
For example, IMAP
and POP3 disabled
at the start of
the account itself,
or creation of the account.
ANDREW SULLIVAN:
That's a common theme.
Disable IMAP and POP3.
You can do that with one
checkbox, by the way.
I noticed that both
Ryan and Red were
talking about enabling single
sign-on to third-party services
using Google Cloud Identity.
Were there some
barriers or problems
you had to overcome
when you did that
with either user resistance or
difficulty with the services?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ: No.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: No.
Right?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
I guess everyone's
familiar with the
Google login, so it's
like they're using it that
their own personal accounts.
I guess what we did
so that it was easy
for them was to emulate how they
do it in their own accounts.
In that same way, once
we enabled, for example,
2FA in the SSO, they
wanted to do it as well
on their own personal accounts.
So we were able
to influence them
and made sure that they're
well aware of security risk
on their own space.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Well, I
noticed a couple of cases
where actually your end user
was a security advocate.
Your end user said, hey, I was
able to improve my security
on my own account,
or in the other case,
your implementation of MDM was
able to save me a security risk
personally.
So was that a case
where they were
able to actually be an advocate
throughout the organization?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ: Yes.
Also, for some reason, we're
treating them as babies
as well.
So that's one of the mandates
really, of Globe telecom.
We want to make sure
that our employees are
being treated properly.
So instead of just telling
them exactly what to do,
or trying to influence
them as well,
that they have to do it on
their own personal space too.
So for example, there were
cases before where Facebook
accounts-- not even
Google accounts--
Facebook accounts on their own
personal space got compromised.
And we told them to
enable 2FA as well.
So it's not really about
just Google and whatsoever.
It's about security
posture across all.
So at the end of the
day, user, whether it's
a personal space
or a company space,
would have the
same security risk.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Great.
OK.
Next question.
We wanted you to share
some tips and tricks.
Things that you do that make
your management experience
with Google Admin better
or that save you time
while administering
G Suite security.
Sure.
Red.
Yeah, Red, you start this time.
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
Well, keep it simple.
What we're doing is go
for the native ones.
If we're not satisfied with
it, we go to automate it
and to get third-party
party solutions.
But as much as possible, we want
to go for the native solutions
and try to lock as soon as
possible before we can--
for example, with
the IMAP and POP3.
At the onset, we
had to disable it,
and not just on G Suite level,
but on the network level.
So even if the
administrator mistakenly
turned on the IMAP
and POP3, there
are certain floors in the
building that are really
locked down across all.
So you cannot use
your IMAP and POP3.
Also, in terms of--
you have to make sure
you have user templates.
I like what they
were saying earlier.
We do that as well
in Globe because we
have a different security team.
We call them ISDP, so
Information, Security, and Data
Privacy team.
And our team is this
information systems group.
So basically, we work
hand-in-hand with them.
So there's operations,
and at the same time,
they maintain their policies.
But we are more and
focusing on the solutions
and implementation
of these solutions.
So as I mentioned
earlier, the templates
that we collaborated with--
it was easy for us to give
awareness to our employees
to the point that, probably,
they're sick of our awareness
already in terms of templates
and use cases and whatever.
But it was helpful for
us to veer them away
from the usual to more of
a higher security posture.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: And
tell me a little more.
When you say security
templates, what do you mean?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
For example,
when you have new hacker
use or whatever issues,
we have a template ready
that we can already
use to communicate fast.
That's one.
To announce new upgrades or
functionalities, that's two.
The third one would be, in terms
of requesting for security.
For example, for
SSO, where you have
to create a project
in GCP, you have
to integrate it with
a project for you
to use the admin APIs of Google.
You have to request
it in a manner,
and you have to explain what
these applications, what
requests, what use
the API is for.
So what we do is to
create that template,
make sure that the
file it properly to us,
and it's a collaborative
template, actually.
So all of our security
personnel would
be able to go through that
template and give their advice,
whether we go through
it with it or not.
PASCAL DALLA TORRE:
Yes, for Veolia,
I would say three major
pillars and tips and tricks.
SSO, we mentioned it.
MDM with the basic ones inside
like pin codes, green locks,
and all that stuff.
And again, two-step
verification.
And again, you really
have to carry on
with this, which is very
important, as we mentioned
before.
Otherwise, you can
explain to your user
that they will have to change
the password on a very,
very, very regular basis, which
can be a pain in the neck.
So maybe a tip to maybe
roll out more broader
this is kind of
two-step verification
is, first of all, to
start with a scope
that you have under control.
People that you know.
One or two key
players that you have.
And you start to
discuss with them.
If they have influence, you
can go and have meetings
with their team explaining why
it's the best way to do it.
And start to elaborate a clear
and understandable process.
Like you identified
the population,
you distribute your
keys, you spend some time
with some users trying to set up
the keys within their accounts.
And I mentioned before
the super admin accounts.
What you do is--
and it's now available
within Google--
you say that this two-step
verification is security key
and only security key.
And the second point is that
you [INAUDIBLE] trusted device.
It means that each
time they login,
they have to play the
security key, no other choice.
So this is really, really great
for those sensitive accounts.
So again, it's
really basic, but it
has to be implemented in
order to enforce security.
ANDREW SULLIVAN:
What I notice here
is this is as much about process
and about putting together
an organizational approach
that gets people involved
in securing their own devices,
rather than just using
the technical solutions.
PASCAL DALLA TORRE:
Well, it is correct.
I mean, a large-scale
company like ours,
and I guess it's also a good
playground even with smaller
companies, there
is no other choice.
If you don't do that, then
it's going to be a total mess.
I mean, I don't see
any options if you
don't have a clear,
understandable process.
ANDREW SULLIVAN: I
couldn't agree more.
Ryan?
RYAN SEIT: Yeah, to
elaborate a little bit more
on what Pascal mentioned
earlier, service
accounts for everything.
Anything that requires an
admin log in or account
to do something
administratively,
have a service account for it.
Don't tie it to a
personal account.
I think continuing along those
lines, Team Drives is great.
Google Team Drives
allows you to--
[APPLAUSE]
Let's hear it for
Google Team Drives.
All right.
Nice.
I'll just drop the mic on that.
Yeah, so Google
Team Drives is great
because it allows you to remove
the actual file from being
attached to a particular user.
User leaves the company, those
files don't go with them.
Although there are methods
of getting around that,
Team Drives is a
great tool that we
are starting to implement
across the entire company
to great success.
Past that, automate
as much as you can.
There are so many things that
we need to do as administrators.
It's very tedious work.
And as you scale, I mean I'm
only speaking for myself.
I'm sure everybody
else on this stage
knows far more better
than I do about this.
But those processes start to
scale when you multiply them
by 10, 20, 30, 40 50%.
It just becomes a nightmare.
So automate.
Google Apps Script.
Fantastic tool.
We use that for onboarding
and offboarding,
so our HR teams are able
to enter information,
the relative name for the user
or the manager of the user,
the start date, if it's a
contract at the end date.
And then it kicks off
automation sending [INAUDIBLE]
to the hiring manager,
creating the actual accounts.
We use a third-party tool
cart called BetterCloud,
which is a fantastic one that
integrates very tightly with G
Suite that allows us to kick
off workflows or automation.
So it'll work with
Slack, et cetera,
and just create all the
accounts we need for day one
when that user starts.
Very little interaction
from our part.
And then conversely, when
they leave, same situation.
It removes everything and
just makes life a lot easier,
and ensures there's
no user error there.
So automation, huge thing.
ANDREW SULLIVAN:
Really appreciate
that with the automation.
Who uses Apps Script
on a regular basis?
Cool.
I definitely want to definitely
want to highlight that.
I want to make sure to allow
some time for questions.
So my last question to y'all,
and how are we on the Dory?
Quite a few questions
on the Dory.
Excellent.
So my last question-- oh,
you've been looking at the Dory?
Excellent.
My last question for you all
is, what new security controls
are you looking forward
to coming from G Suite
that we don't have ye?
Especially ones in beta.
PASCAL DALLA TORRE: Well.
The first two are the DLP,
but we know it's coming.
Because that tool is prevention.
As long as you know
at your company what
sensitive data means, then
it's great to use such a tool.
But the first thing is to define
what the sensitive data is,
which is the first problem.
But it can be quite powerful
once you have such a tool.
The second one is related
to maybe more mobility.
And we have such a project
within our company.
Secure anytime,
anywhere, any device.
It means mobility everywhere.
And I'm talking about
context aware access.
And you can authorize
some people to access,
according to a certain
context, to some resources.
And this is also
a very great tool
that we've been
assessing for a while.
Now, Andrew starts
my shopping list.
So actually, we faced an issue
which is called API control.
We would like to get more
granular control related
to APIs versus
domain-wide delegation.
I said before that we try to
integrate to more SES solution.
And those solution, they tend
to consume some resources just
with resources like
calendars, drives, and so on.
And they ask for
domain-wide delegation.
So again, at a
company like ours,
it means accessing
the whole domain.
So we would like more
granular things like this.
Another tool we
could be great, we
discussed before
sensitive accounts.
Super admin accounts
is one category.
But we have also all
the delegated admins.
And we have customized role.
And one of the problems is
that some they use some roles,
but sometimes they don't use it.
It would be so great to have a
tool that could say, hey, guy,
now you're not using this
customized role for now three
months.
OK?
This is the list.
We would like to get
rid of this custom role
because you don't need it.
It still is a privilege.
And we don't have
such a tool, and it
would be great to have that.
So OK, I'll let Ryan talk,
but I have some other ideas
like Management API.
I mentioned we have 1,000
organizational units.
And it's quite difficult to
have an idea about the security,
how it has been implemented
just in one click.
So it would be great to
have a report right away
to say, oh guy, look, your
configuration is exactly
like this.
Should I carry on, Andrew?
Or should I give the
microphone to someone else?
ANDREW SULLIVAN: Thank you.
Ryan and Red, and I can't
make any commitments
to anything new.
But please watch
out for the betas.
RYAN SEIT: So looking
forward to being
able to share Drive data with
external non-G Mail or G Suite
partners.
That's really exciting for us.
We do work with
tons of vendors that
force us to use another service,
which will remain nameless.
But we are still utilizing
two different file sharing
services, which causes some
confusion within the company
on what to store where.
Past that, MDM, the
functionality for Chrome OS,
Android, IOS, fantastic.
Endpoint verification is a
thing for Windows and Mac.
I'm really excited to see
where that goes down the line.
If we can consolidate the other
management tools that we're
using currently, which will
I guess also remain nameless,
it would be great to do that all
from within G Suite, because it
does it really well.
Yeah.
That's the only two
things I want right now.
ANDREW SULLIVAN:
Awesome, thank you.
Red?
RED JAQUES BERNALDEZ:
Yeah, on my end,
actually, they've said
a lot of requests.
Particularly is
the context aware.
I know it's in beta already.
I haven't tested one out.
But context aware,
basically it's more of--
and actually one
of the questions
here was locking down specific
access to a specific location,
whether it's through an
IP or a specific time.
That would be great,
because we have
a lot of temporary
employees as well, which
we want to make sure that
they're only using it
on a specific location.
Another thing would be, I guess
more on the Drive as well.
On the Team Drive.
Yeah, that's one of
the particular concerns
because we are collaborating
with different G Suite users.
So we want to make sure that
we can still collaborate
with them, but at the same time,
the files would remain with us
and will not be
destroyed whatsoever
once the person is cut
out from our organization.
ANDREW SULLIVAN:
Great, thank you.
PASCAL DALLA TORRE: Just one
point is related to extension.
Chrome extension.
It's an issue for us because
users, they use them a lot.
And we [INAUDIBLE]
have no visibility.
If we could have a
tool to have more, say,
easy to whitelist things
like that, you know.